jeff bezos currently has 69
billion dollars more than bill gates and
it likely won't be long until
elon musk and mark zuckerberg take bill
over as well
but despite this bill gates actually
towers over his fellow billionaires
in terms of wealth he actually never
lost his position
of world switches person and likely
won't for decades to come
and here's why
well first of all the numbers that we
see on forbes and bloomberg
don't really mean much these are more
theoretical estimates
as opposed to real wealth as in all of
these cases
their wealth is completely on paper now
this isn't necessarily a bad thing the
average person
a multi-millionaire or even a
multi-billionaire having the vast
majority of their wealth
in paper assets is not a problem yes
you would be severely prone to market
fluctuations
however you would in most cases still
retain the ability to cash out
completely
within hours days and in the worst case
scenario
weeks but when you hold tens of billions
in one asset
it literally becomes impossible to ever
realize the money you have
if we take a look at jeff bezos for the
past couple of years
he has consistently been liquidating
about 3 billion
of his amazon stake every year this year
he actually over doubled that to 7.2
billion dollars
but even if he continued this rate and
his wealth remained stagnant
it would take him 27 years to simply
liquidate his current wealth
of 194 billion dollars but here's the
thing
amazon stock has grown 38.04 per year
on average since 1997.
as a result his roughly 177 billion
dollar stake in amazon today
would grow by about 60 billion dollars
in 12 months time
even if the growth slowed to 25 he would
gain
44 billion at 15 he would gain 26
billion
and even at a market average of 8 he
would gain
14 billion with that being said even by
doubling down
on liquidating his position jeff bezos
is only able to cash out a small
fraction
of how much his position grows on an
annual basis
but why can't jeff bezos just sell at a
faster rate to make up for the growth
well as you would expect excessive stock
selling is not
seen in a positive light by the other
shareholders of amazon
who hold over 1 trillion dollars the
founder
selling tens of billions per year raises
several questions for shareholders
as to whether the founder no longer
believes in the future of the company
or do they believe that company growth
will slow and so on and so forth
as a result these top billionaires are
only able to cash out of a small portion
of their stake
every year without crashing the stock of
their entire companies
considering this jeff bezos will never
be able to sell out of amazon through
the market
there is another option which would be
to sell a stake to other corporations
but there's only a handful of companies
that are even capable of buying out
significant chunks
of such stakes and it's not a guarantee
that any of them will even be interested
also something else to consider is that
when these individuals didn't sell out
when they had a few billion
or even when they had 10 or 20 billion
it's very unlikely that they'll be
willing to sell out to another company
when they have several tens of billions
or hundreds of billions
with all of that being said it's
impossible for jeff bezos to fully cash
out of amazon
and this is the same case with virtually
everyone else
at the very top elon musk has about 70
of his wealth in tesla and the rest in
spacex mark zuckerberg has
95 of his wealth in facebook bernard
arnold
has over 90 of his wealth and christian
dior louis vuitton
and hermes nearly 100 percent of mukesh
and bonnie's wealth
comes from reliance industries 92 of
steve ballmer's wealth comes from
microsoft
about 95 of larry page and sergey brin
70 billion dollar fortunes
come from google all these guys have
essentially
all their wealth and one maybe two
companies
and this is because the only way to go
to that much wealth
at a relatively young age is by
achieving super high growth rates
on a super concentrated portfolio so
though these guys theoretically have 70
80 90 194 billion dollars in wealth they
would struggle to come up with even 10
billion dollars in the 12-month time
period
now that's no scoffable number
whatsoever
but there are two guys who squash all
the rest
which would of course be bill gates and
warren buffett
warren buffett has always been super
diversified
as that's how he grew his wealth unlike
the rest
warren buffett does have some
unproportionately large holdings
with the largest being apple berkshire
hathaway
owns 89.4 billion dollars worth of apple
stock
but with the portfolio that was already
worth 707 billion dollars in 2018.
this is only 10 to 15 percent of their
holdings
during regular times moreover his
company
owns 47 different stocks with the other
46 stocks
taking up only a few percent each if
that
considering this warren buffett has the
power to liquidate
the vast majority of his entire
portfolio within just a few weeks
and this is precisely what he wants done
after his death warren buffett wants 90
of his wealth liquidated and invested
into index funds following his death
and he wants these index fund holdings
as well as his last nine percent of
wells
to be donated to various charities that
he has pre-selected
considering that this is his plan it's
likely that about 90
of warren buffett's wealth is easily
liquidatable due to a strong
diversification
this means that warren buffett is
capable of coming up with roughly 72
billion dollars in a matter of weeks and
even if the real number falls short of
that coming in at 50 or 60 billion
this is still multiples more than all
the tech billionaires
other than bill gates bill gates has
been aggressively diversifying
for nearly three decades at this point
and today
bill gates is even more diversified than
warren buffett
bill gates did make his money really
young and
consequently in the 1980s and early
1990s
he faced the same problem that other
tech moguls face today
which is extreme concentration he could
have just left it in microsoft and let
it ride like his peers
but he preferred to diversify and step
away
consequently bill gates has reduced his
stake in microsoft from 45 percent
to just 1.36 percent over the past 30
years
now of course 1.36 of microsoft
is still 22.1 billion dollars
despite that bill gates can completely
exit microsoft
if he's so desired plus 1.36 percent
is far less than his peers 15 20
30 stakes if bill gates chose against
liquidating like his peers till later in
the company's life cycle
he could have easily held on to over a
third of the company
meaning that he would be worth well over
500 billion dollars today
but of course if he did that he would
have just been a paper billionaire like
most of his friends
and he would struggle to come up with
just a fraction of that
so it was likely a much wiser decision
to diversify
anyways bill gates decided to pour money
into warren buffett's
berkshire hathaway which now accounts
for 8.2 billion dollars of his wealth
aside from this he also has billions
scattered across several stable industry
leaders
such as waste management inc canadian
national railway corporation
walmart caterpillar and several more to
make things even better
bill gates only has a little over 60 of
his money in the stock market
itself this article actually makes it
seem like bill gates is really
aggressive in the stock market
but i think they should take a look at
some of the other billionaire's
diversification
first anyways this means that 30 to 40
of his wealth is not even in the stock
market and
that it is spread across other asset
classes such as real estate
bonds and even cash as you can see there
are only a handful of individuals
if any who boast the same level of
diversification
as bill gates but what does all of this
even mean
well other than his 22 billion microsoft
stock
bill gates could liquidate the vast
majority of his portfolio
within just a few months and even with
the microsoft holding
bill could likely sell about 10 billion
in one go
with no problems in other words bill
gates can come up with
115 billion dollars in cash pre-tax
in just a couple of months of course
there are saudi princes
and kings who can conjure up even more
on a second's notice
but in the free market economy to put
that in perspective
at jeff bezos current liquidation rate
he would need
2.9 trillion dollars to enjoy the same
liquidation power
as bill gates and this is the same case
with the other tech moguls as well
considering that it will take decades
for these guys to achieve wealth in the
multi-trillions
and or achieve the same level of
diversification as bill gates
bill gates will lead this race for at
least the next few decades
unless of course he gives it all away at
the end of the day
none of this really matters as all of
them have way more money
than they could ever reasonably spend
but technically
that's how bill gates and warren buffett
trample their billionaire peers
in terms of tangible wealth did you guys
realize how much more tangible wealth
bill gates has access to
comment that down below also if you guys
enjoyed the depth of analysis
then make sure to drop a like and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys
on the next one
you